cooler this morning wasn't it guys oh
yeah i had the hoodie on the sweats when
i went for my morning walk yeah with the
dogs it was nice wait til you see
tomorrow morning really yes get out
sweat
well you've been working out she really
has been working out
chief milo just ted florendo in with all
the details i don't want to get hurt
with this weather
temperature is going to be chilly
tomorrow morning i'm going to stay way
over here maybe i should move a little
bit over no christian you're good let's
just not give anything
for her to throw
okay
live look outside guys i love this shot
here from rainbow west cliff
particularly because right on the bottom
of the screen is that burger king i go
to on occasion i just realized that
great shot though sunset tonight now at
6 31 or i'm 4 31 i believe so daylight
saving time ends right so it's getting
darker quicker air quality in the good
range for ozone and carbon however none
of this is going to happen dust small
particular matter like exhaust for your
cars that's up a little bit to moderate
range right now we're just having a lot
of wind to scour that out of here we
certainly haven't seen any rain to get
rid of that at all currently outside
let's start it off 69 degrees sky canyon
along with centennial hills along with
aliante temperatures cooler than
yesterday at this hour right so we're in
the low 70s to high 60s across the
valley here north las vegas whitney
ranch 72 68 henderson 69 mountains edge
65 for southern highlands and anthem at
67 degrees kj really has been working
out
67 good thing we got a good health plan
here
68 mesquite lafayette 75 degrees uh
let's take a look at the lower 48 states
why is it colder to the north look at
this salt lake 39 31 denver the mile
high
twin cities at 35 degrees the reason for
that okay is we have this dip in the jet
stream here this is where the cooler air
is at we're still within that dip just a
little bit high pressure coming in off
the coast here though is bringing us
those north winds that we saw today and
down the colorado river valley will we
see those winds tomorrow yes for the
colorado valley yes for the lake
tomorrow for here not so bad those winds
will be a lot lighter tomorrow for your
thursday this is the big story though
your overnight lows are going to get
chilly cold for some of you we're
looking at the mid 40s for summerlin 44
for you 46 mountains edge 48 downtown 48
green valley this is sweta weather
for tomorrow swarawada tomorrow
41 for prompt
46 for boulder city look at death valley
even 56 degrees for death valley
tonight 48 degrees overnight we'll see
more clouds but still look at partly
cloudy skies lighter winds tonight and
overnight 68 for tomorrow still going to
see a mix of sun and clouds in the
forecast for tomorrow 66 is our normal
so we'll be just above average for this
time of year and here is your eight day
forecast guys all right so we're in the
low 70s we're on cruise control through
sunday
next week we brought back the twerking
turkey for christian
mid 60s
back over to you